bien je pense qu'on va pouvoir régaler
bonjour bonjour à tous et à vous toutes
j'aurai tout d'abord excusez le prix
d'encombrant qui est revenu pour
[Musique]
retenu pour des affaires personnelles
voilà
vers mes chers collègues nous
accueillons ce matin le 8 amiral
d'escades Pascal osseur directeur
général de la Fondation Méditerranée
d'études stratégiques amiral soirée des
e soyez le bienvenu devant notre
commission après avoir entendu le
colonel Michel Goya et le général de
Cora aérien Bruno Clermont qui nous ont
livré leur vision de terriens et
d'aviateurs sur la guerre en Ukraine
audition qui je le rappelle ont été
particulièrement suivis nous sommes
heureux d'avoir le regard d'un marin sur
la nouvelle donne géopolitique entraînée
par ce conflit déclenché il y a bientôt
un an
je rappelle que vous avez passé 37 ans
dans la Marine en tant qu'officier dans
les forces de surface période durant
laquelle vous avez notamment commandé le
jambes puis à l'état-major des armées en
cabinet ministériel et à la Direction
générale de l'armement en 2015 vous avez
été nommé préfet maritime de la Manche
et de la Mer du Nord avant de rejoindre
Toulon trois ans plus tard pour prendre
la tête de la Fondation méditerranéenne
d'études stratégiques institut de
réflexion sur le bassin méditerranéen et
le Moyen-Orient à la lumière de vos
différentes expériences vous pourrez
nous présenter votre analyse des
événements sur le terrain et les
enseignements que nous pouvons en tirer
tant au plan géostratégique que pour nos
armées par ailleurs si la dimension aéro
terrestre du conflit auraien
ukrainien pardon et la plus commentée
ces aspects navals ne doivent paraître
occultées c'est en effet depuis la mer
qui ont été tirés de nombreux missiles
calibres contre des objectifs terrestres
afin d'appuyer l'invasion russe
de même la domination initiale de la mer
Noire et de la mère d'Azov par la marine
russe a rapidement été contestée par
l'Ukraine avec la destruction du
croiseur russe Moskva le 14 avril ou
encore le retrait russe de l'île des
serpents en juillet dernier ce
rééquilibrage a été permis par les
matériels fournis à l'Ukraine artillerie
à longue portée Émile anti navire mais
également par l'usage de nouvelles armes
telles que les drones navales sur tous
ces points l'éclairage que vous pourrez
nous apporter sera particulièrement
utile vous pourrez également nous
indiquer les répercussions de ce conflit
dans d'autres zones en mer
Méditerranéenne par exemple ou encore en
mer Baltique au-delà du conflit
ukrainien nous avons examiné la semaine
dernière un rapport sur la stratégie
française dans la dopacifique nos
collègues ont rappelé l'importance de
cette zone et la nécessité d'y renforcer
la présence française ceux qui passent
en particulier par une augmentation des
moyens de nos armées nous souhaiterions
vous entendre sur ce sujet majeur enfin
et de manière liée vous nous direz le
regard que vous portez sur les annonces
du président de la République lors de
ses vœux aux armées le 30 janvier le 20
janvier dernier qu'il s'agit de
l'augmentation des dépenses militaires
comme des prix priorités identifiés qui
est-ce qui se les contours de la future
loi de programmation militaire après un
propos liminaire d'une quinzaine de
minutes je donnerai la parole à mes
collègues pour un échange de
questions-réponses je vous rappelle que
cette audition est captée et diffusée
sur le site internet du Sénat amiral
vous avez la parole
monsieur vice-président merci beaucoup
de votre accueil mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs merci de me
donner l'occasion de vous donner un
point de vue moi je vous parle d'abord
comme vous l'avez dit de trois points de
vue différents
le premier en gros presque petite
vingtaine d'années dans les forces de
surface de la marine le groupe aeronaval
la défense aérienne
déployée pendant ces années de
d'interface j'y reviendrai géopolitique
en quelque sorte d'intermédiaire de
géopolitique une vingtaine d'années dans
ce qu'on a dans les relations
internationales et ce qu'on appelle le
politique homelitaire donc à Paris est
beaucoup plus proche vous de vous les
politiques donc un niveau beaucoup plus
stratégique et puis maintenant bientôt
cinq années à la tête de ce sintank donc
qui fait de la
géostratégie de la géopolitique sur le
flanc sud et je vous allez voir que je
vais vous reparler du flan sud un peu
paradoxalement puisque au départ le
thème c'est plutôt à l'Est mais mon idée
mon idée force c'est que ce qui se passe
à l'Est illustre un monde dans lequel
notre Sud notre Sud à nous Européens
français et particulièrement chrysogènes
et doit nous préoccuper doit normalement
vous préoccuper considérablement voilà
voilà l'idée générale et évidemment ça
va m'amener à parler de la mer de
l'Ukraine bien sûr c'est l'objet et de
la mer donc j'ai compris qu'il fallait
que je fasse cours donc je vais vous
donner plutôt des des idées forces
en parlant en partant du général vers le
particulier je vais vous parler de du
monde géopolitique tel qu'il est tel que
la guerre en Ukraine illustre je vais
vous brosser tel que je les vois et là
c'est l'opérationnel qui va parler les
conséquences technico opérationnelles
générales finalement de cette guerre que
vous avez déjà savoir couper des tas de
choses je pense que qu'on dit mes
prédécesseurs je vais faire un focus sur
le maritime on dire qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire sur le plan maritime et puis
j'ai essayé très humblement de tirer des
leçons pour la France en disant que ça
veut dire quoi pas pour nous nous
Français voilà donc ça fait assez
ambitieux en 15 minutes mais je vais je
vais essayer de vous donner des des mots
clés et je suis prêt évidemment à
développer autant que vous le souhaitez
je suis à votre disposition je suis
extrêmement fier qu'un signe tant que
provincial basé à Toulon
et accès à la représentation de la
nation parce que je pense qu'il y a une
pensée stratégique en dehors du
périphérique et vous me donnez
l'occasion de d'essayer de vous le
prouver j'en suis j'en suis très honoré
conséquences géopolitique l'Ukraine en
fait n'a pas changé la donne parce que
c'est un événement majeur donc ça change
mais en même temps ça change pas la
nature de ce qu'on avait vu avant nous
mais je suis pas le seul à la FMS comme
dans d'autres c'est une temps comme
d'autres observateurs on décrivait le
monde déjà avant pour expliquer qu'il
était en train de changer le premier la
première conséquence c'est que la
géopolitique revient moi je suis rentré
dans un en 1980 dans la marine
c'était le début d'une phase qui s'est
accélérée après la chute du mur mais de
convergence du monde en une seule vous
voyez le poste historique post-national
post-industriel l'économie générale
était était était
dominé tout il y a plus de politique à
faire il y a plus de la gouvernance et
puis on devait tous fusionner et
d'ailleurs le signe tank la FMS a été
créé en 1990 son objectif explicite
était de rallier la Rive-Sud à la
Rive-Nord au modèle de la rive nord donc
en fait transformer en européen le
bassin méditerranéen d'ailleurs
dans le processus de Barcelone
simplement en 2010 toute la Méditerranée
devait être une union douanière donc un
marché commun donc vous voyez donc
c'était signé en 94 en 94 les gens
disaient en 2010 bien entendu le Maroc
et la Turquie faisait partie de l'Union
européenne et toute la Méditerranée
devait être une
un marché commun bon on est très loin
parce qu'en fait au lieu de cette
convergence on avait vous observer une
divergence une fragmentation même du
monde et l'Ukraine l'a évidemment montré
et cette fragmentation elle se met elle
se matérialise et l'Ukraine la remontée
aussi par une tension Est-Ouest majeure
donc l'Occident d'un côté la Russie la
Chine de l'autre et là aussi c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un peu un
retour vers le futur quand vous regardez
les penseurs géostratégiques de les
stratégistes j'allais dire de tournant
du XIXe siècle donc man Mac Kinder
spikeman pour l'entre-deux-guer ils
avaient déjà d'une certaine façon
théoriser ça les grandes puissances
continentales contre la thalassocratie
les gens qui ont les matières premières
et ceux qui font le commerce et le
commerce et le maritime et spikeman
pendant l'entre-deux-guer à théorisé le
Rimland vous savez cette zone interface
entre entre finalement la Chine et la et
la Russie et le monde maritime
occidentale je sais pas mais en tout cas
americano anglo-saxon et cette zone
interface c'était là les tensions ont
lieu alors je vais vous montrer une
carte parce que j'essaye j'avais prévu
quelques cartes mais je comme je vais
aller vite
bon c'est pas grave
faut que je monte quelque chose
peut-être
bon je suis désolé
peu importe peu importe mais quand vous
regardez la carte de l'OCS
l'Organisation de coopération de
Shanghai qui regroupe finalement ce que
mckinder appelait le Horseland voilà la
voilà celle-là par exemple voyez ça ça
c'est bon je je c'est une grille de
lecture du monde tel qu'il est cette
grille là elle a été décrite il y a plus
il y a 100 ans il y a 100 ans donc il y
a une espèce de retour de l'histoire qui
est quand même intéressant et si vous
passez la suivante s'il vous plaît
voilà ça c'est la carte de l'OCS
l'Organisation de coopération de
Shanghai qui est une forme de
structuration politique économique du de
ce que mckinder appelait le Heartland il
y a plus de 100 ans même
voilà qui se perd sous nos yeux
donc donc donc cette tension Est-Ouest
elle est là et elle a un impact pour
nous Français c'est elle s'accompagne
d'une désoxydantalisation c'est à dire
que le modèle
occidental qui a
été là si vous voulez merci le modèle
occidental qui a qui a qui a marqué qui
a marqué
l'avancée du monde géopolitique enfin de
la façon dont les relations
internationales se sont structurées
depuis au moins la deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'est accéléré depuis les
années 80 le libéralisme économique
l'Internet etc
et la Chute du Mur une fois encore et
ben c'est arrêté voilà s'est arrêté et
des modèles alternatifs arrivent et
c'est clair que ça nous pose à nous une
question parce que c'est beaucoup moins
confortable parce qu'on avait prévu
c'est un impact sur le droit
international qui était très
occidentalisé en tout cas perçu comme
occidentalisé et c'est un monde beaucoup
moins désigné beaucoup beaucoup plus
désinhibé en termes d'emploi de la
violence parce que parce que les modèles
sont différents et que les gens qui
veulent remettre en cause le modèle et
ben ils ont pas de de de fausse à dire
Jean-Paul la violence si nécessaire donc
c'est quand même très inconfortable pour
nous derrière ça deuxième deuxième
facteur géopolitique une fois encore qui
révélé par l'Ukraine mais qui
préexistait c'est le sud c'est que à
partir du moment où il y a
la désoxydantalisation arrive il y a les
plaques tectoniques géopolitiques
bougent l'Est se croire l'Ouest diminue
il y a un espace pour les autres et les
autres c'est ce que Poutine appelle le
sud global c'est un peu évidemment ça ça
recouvre des tas de réalité différente
mais c'est une vraie réalité les
puissances qui sont ni à l'Est ni au ni
à l'ouest se disent pour beaucoup
d'entre elles on a une carte à jouer
voilà on a une carte à jouer qui est
autonome elle s'émancipe alors souvent
de la tutelle américaine du temps de
l'Occident vainqueur mais elle est donc
elle s’émancipe elle est plus forte
qu'avant parce que la mondialisation a
profité au sud et
quand on lui demande de choisir elle est
plutôt vers elle choisit plutôt à l'est
et ça doit nous poser des questions ça
doit nous poser une question pourquoi
est-ce que alors pourquoi on pourra
reparler je veux pas je veux pas aller
trop loin troisième facteur
je réduis encore une fois plus la focale
l'Afrique dans le sud il y a l'Afrique
l'Afrique c'est un sujet particulier
d'abord pour nous Européens parce que
c'est en face de chez nous c'est comme
un continent en pleine exposition
expansion démographique et qui en plus
en crise économique structurelle en
crise sociale politique sociétale enfin
je veux pas vous passer nous on a à la
FMS des cartes sur le bassin
méditerranéen qui montre que quel que
soit le critère qu'on prend que ce soit
l'économie la démographie
l'organisation sociale le traitement des
femmes le covid la corruption etc on a
toujours la même carte le Nord et le Sud
et quand on la compare avec les années
passées les couleurs divergent chaque
année un peu plus c'est à dire qu'en
fait au lieu d'avoir ce qu'on avait
prévu du temps du processus de Barcelone
dans les années 90 cette convergence des
deux rives et je vous ai expliqué
finalement cette européanisation de nos
voisins qui se faisaient quasiment
mécaniquement la question était de
savoir comment on allait gérer ça en
douceur c'est plus c'est pas du tout ça
ce qui se passe ce qui se passe c'est
une divergence doublée d'un antagonisme
d'un ressentiment très fort et et ces
structurelles c'est-à-dire quoi il y a
aucune raison que ça s'arrange tous les
paramètres et l'Ukraine la guerre du
crâne le covid les crises économiques
diverses et variées la pandémie fallait
pandémie à venir
tout et le réchauffement climatique bien
sûr j'aurais du conseil comme ça
tous les paramètres qu'on voit au taux
extérieur qui agissent sur cet
environnement
selon toutes les analyses n'auront comme
un effet que d'accroître la divergence
entre ces deux rives et ces deux rives
elles sont elle est à notre
directe proximité donc structurellement
sous tension un phénomène idéologique
qui s'accroît parce qu'il se trouve que
cette Rive-Sud c'est une rive qui est
marquée par un par l'Islam et l'islam
depuis au moins au moins la révolution
islamique d'Iran de 79 est un islam
revendicatif qui demande qui qui est une
espèce de fierté de revendication qui a
remplacé finalement le marxisme en terme
de logiciels intellectuel pour pour
regarder le Nord regardez les autres et
donc c'est un espèce d'Islam militant
qui qui rajoute encore de l'attention à
la tension donc il y a une tension
structurelle rajoutée par ce facteur
musulman enfin islamique plutôt et puis
et puis cette tension estos croissante
qu'on observe et ben elle
instrumentalise ses tensions
c'est-à-dire qu'en sud vous avez la
Russie qui se déchaîne la Chine qui en
rajoute une couche la Turquie qui
rajoute tous les gens tous les pays qui
sont finalement qui ont un problème
ou qui se disent c'est le moment de
reprendre notre place et donc de
profiter de cette affaiblissement
temporaire ou pas ou structurel c'est à
nous de le voir de l'Ouest en général et
de l'Europe en particulier toutes ces
puissances jouent de cette de ce maillon
faible extraordinaire que représente
l'Afrique pour l'Europe parce que parce
qu'on n'a pas réussi à gérer cette
divergence structurelle et moi je pense
que c'est un un énorme finalement
finalement l'Afrique pour finir sur
cette partie géopolitique c'est le front
indirect de la guerre du crâne et si les
choses tournent mal
pour les Russes pour Poutine en Ukraine
il serait absolument pas surprenant de
voir de plus en plus d'activisme
anti-français anti-européen mais enfin
il se trouve que les Français sont les
européens les plus présents en Afrique
sur ce flanc sud donc c'est un c'est un
donc c'est je répète le raisonnement
c'est pas l'Ukraine qui a créé les
problèmes au sud et c'est pas la Russie
qui crée le problème au sud on a on a un
vrai problème structurel
des divergences sociales économiques
gigantesques qui sont parfaitement
connus par les gens donc la sacrée une
des frustrations absolument énorme c'est
doublé d'un ressentiment fort c'est
c'est l'islam radical lui donne une
logique à tout ça même si c'est bien sûr
pas l'alpha et l'oméga des choses et
l'antagonisme des des puissances
revanchardes et révisionnistes on
rajoute une couche en quelque sorte
voilà donc et puis si vous prenez tous
les paramètres extérieurs réchauffement
crise pandémique crise économique etc ça
va encore rajouter une couche aux
couches donc vous avez compris le
message mon message c'est que le ce Sud
là et cette Afrique là et pour nous très
important deuxième point les
conséquences techniques enfin technico
opérationnel alors là c'est le militaire
qui parle que je vois et je vais passer
vite parce que je suis convaincu
connaissant mes prédécesseurs qui ont
déjà abordé ça de façon très précise
évidemment moi moi en tant que militaire
la première chose mais je crois que tout
le monde le dit première conclusion
c'est que la dissuasion nucléaire
fonctionne tout tout le monde sait enfin
je trouve il y a peu de choses où on
peut être sûr de sûr mais si l'Ukraine
avait eu la bombe Poutine n'aurait pas
attaqué si Poutine n'avait pas la bombe
il n'aurait pas attaqué parce qu'il
aurait craint des riposte beaucoup plus
fortes sur son territoire et si les
Occidentaux n'avaient pas la bombe et
ben il est fort probable que Poutine
n'en aurait profité pour aller en
Lituanie ou ailleurs en tout cas il
serait beaucoup moins prudent pour
éviter l'escalade donc on a une
démonstration en grandeur réelle que la
dissuasion nucléaire fonctionne
par contre ce n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de la sécurité mondiale mais ça
on le savait on le savait
donc sous le sous le pas sous le
parapluie nucléaire ou sous la voûte
nucléaire il peut se passer des choses
et des tensions et le monde nous le
montre deuxième
conséquence générale technique
opérationnelle enfin qui pas propre à la
Marine qui est générale qui moi me
marque c'est le fameux débat sur
technologie versus masse masse étant
quantité logistique soutien BITD la
masse c'est vraiment ça c'est que la
capacité de produire des outils
militaires
c'est un débat sans fin et à mon avis
c'est un débat qui n'a pas il n'y a pas
un vainqueur d'ailleurs ce qui se passe
en Ukraine nous le monde d'un côté
l'Ukraine et l'Occident c'est la
technologie de l'autre côté la Russie
c'est la masse et on voit qu'on arrive à
un espèce de statu quo parce que il
manque toujours de la masse à l'ouest et
de la technologie à l'est et donc il
faut les deux il faut les deux je pense
à un débat c'est hyper stérile de dire
privilégions l'un plutôt que l'autre
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il est plus
facile de développer de la masse quand
on a de la techno que développer la
techno quand on a de la masse je
pourrais développer si vous le souhaitez
cette idée donc on part sur ce plan là
on ne part pas avec un désavantage mais
parce qu'on a de la technologie à
l'ouest et on en a encore en France je
dis encore parce que on a on a bien un
petit peu perdu un autre débat classique
et vieux alors pour le coup depuis
Tocqueville presque oui depuis
Tocqueville puisqu'il a écrit dessus il
y a donc 150 ans c'est le l'Occident les
démocraties sont molles et manque de
force morale elles sont fragiles ce qui
est vrai donc ce vieux débat est-ce que
les les
démocraties sont-elles plus fragiles que
les autres ou au contraire est-ce que la
démocratie donne une force morale plus
forte en fait les deux comme toujours
oui les démocraties une fragilité
initiale parce que des sociétés ouvertes
des sociétés de débat et donc c'est
assez facile d'instrumentaliser les
conflits les débats internes et
Tocqueville avait une expression il
disait les démocraties ont toujours du
mal à commencer les guerres et toujours
du mal à les finir et je crois que c'est
assez vrai puisque une fois que le
peuple par contre s'empare de la guerre
de la conflictualité là on est
d'ailleurs dans ce que clausvitz qui est
pas un contemporain mais pas loin de de
Tocqueville dit une fois que le peuple a
pris la passion commence à venir et à ce
moment-là on monte il y a un risque pour
le coup de monter aux extrêmes mais donc
je trouve que l'Ukraine ne montre bien
la démocratie vulnérable oui on est
attaqué en permanence par les par les
par les réseaux sociaux les machins et
et
c'est une fragilité interne que nous
avons
mais en même temps les soldats
Ukrainiens savent pourquoi ils meurent
alors que les soldats russes ils ne
savent pas très bien et finalement c'est
Wagner ou là les gens ils se meurent
pour l'argent qui se balent mieux parce
que moi ils ont ils sont payés ils ont
des équipements ils sont bien payés donc
ils savent pourquoi ils se battent alors
que le construire US il sait pas trop
pourquoi il se bat ça l'empêchera pas
d'aller mourir mais mais c'est pas la
même chose que le caporal
ukrainien qui était en fait
informaticien dans le civil et qui s'est
engagé sous les drapeaux bon voilà
depuis la Révolution française on sait
que la démocratie elle a un pouvoir de
fédération des peuples qui a écrasé
l'Europe c'est comme ça que après la
Révolution française l'Europe tremblée
devant la France ce qui est pas du tout
un regret de ma part mais c'est une
illustration à mon avis très bonne avec
aussi pour les forces morales la
question clé du leadership
donc je veux pas je pourrais aller plus
loin mais en temps de paix on suscite un
leadership de temps de paix et c'est
tout à fait justifié quand on passe au
temps de guerre en temps de crise c'est
pas le même type de leadership dont on a
besoin et ça c'est compliqué à gérer
mais on l'a vu dans nos histoires
Paul Raynaud et
qui a joué la qui a fait la transition
était mal à l'aise dans cette transition
il a tout compris mais il avait il a il
avait pas finalement la personnalité
pour répondre au programme il a tout
compris puisqu'il a pris de Gaulle dans
son gouvernement mais ça suffisait pas
pour pour changer complètement de
politique parce qu'il avait pas l'étoffe
en fait le profil pour pour l'événement
qui était face à lui
continuez dans les dans les dans les
bien sûr dans les dans la les
conclusions technologiques aux
militaires l'importance des
technologiques de rupture mais ça donc
les drones les satellites le cyber les
réseaux toute la communication le
renseignement évidemment l'intelligence
artificielle pour gérer cette donnée
cette masse de données en fait c'est la
boucle qu'on appelle Oda vous avez déjà
dû entendre je pense mes prédécesseurs
en faisant parler observation observer
orientée décidé et agir cette boucle de
décision opérationnelle qui se
raccourcit qui sera considérablement et
là on a maintenant les outils pour le
raccourcir très rapidement et ça donne
un point un avantage considérable il y a
moi j'ai un besoin de vieux militaires
aussi qui me frappe c'est que la
prolifération des armes au dessus des
missiles des drones des bombes de
précision qui sont maintenant
généralisées partout font que il y a une
vraie problématique de défense aérienne
générale qui se pose de façon beaucoup
plus cruciale aujourd'hui que il y a 30
ans parce que on a proliféré de partout
et que ça coûte rien et que c'est devenu
très simple à employer et aujourd'hui
donc cette menace qui était quand même
une menace qu'on nous occidentaux on
faisait peser sur les autres mais enfin
peu de chance de l'avoir aujourd'hui nul
ne peut dire que le territoire français
ne peut pas être touché par par une
munition sensible qui était aussi
performante que les nôtres aussi
performante je vais donner un exemple
précis parce que sinon ça n'a pas de
mais les la marine algérienne a des
sous-marins kilos modernisés sous-marin
diesel mais mais très très
furtif très discret avec des missiles
calibres qui sont des missiles de MDC en
fait qui sont des missiles de croisière
qui ont déportés qui peuvent très bien
le territoire national à partir d'un
sous-marin donc de façon très discrète
finalement et pas et pas signable et
donc pas attribuable ça c'est un vrai
sujet qu'on avait absolument pas il y a
20 ans et là nul ne peut dire que le
territoire national ne peut pas être
touché par une arme de ce type-là et
est-ce qu'on peut dire que la dissuasion
nucléaire va nous protéger de ça c'est
pas crédible donc on a un sujet là qui
je donne cet exemple on pourrait en
donner plein d'autres bien sûr mais mais
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'on ait en tête et dernier point
justement de façon générale c'est on
voit que la diffusion nucléaire ne
protège pas tout elle est très efficace
mais mais mais mais mais mais pas
exclusive on voit que maintenant on a
une vulnérabilité une équilibre enfin on
a rééquilibrer les forces dans le
conventionnel il faut penser à une
capacité de dissuasion conventionnelle
c'est-à-dire de dire à quelqu'un oui
bien sûr vous avez les capacités de
taper Marseille de taper Toulon de taper
un Drom com mais nous avons les
capacités sans passer à l'arme nucléaire
qui serait complètement pas du tout
réaliste et pas crédible nous avons la
capacité de représailles tellement
massive que vous êtes dissuadé de le
faire je pense qu'une question qu'il
faut qu'il faut se poser et qu'on se
posait pas dans ces termes-là il y a 30
ans parce que parce que la menace
extérieure était trop faible ou quand
elle était forte elle était à parité et
là on était avec le dans le dans le
spectre du nucléaire conséquence
maritime quelques points dans un monde
complètement qui reste mondialisé parce
que le monde se fragmente la
géopolitique vient mais elle a pas
supprimer la mondialisation et la
mondialisation la mondialisation a été
économique et l'économie c'est le
maritime donc dès qu'il y a une
interférence avec un flux maritime ça
devient une perturbation mondiale donc
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on
ait en tête tous ce qui fait que la
maritime même un théâtre aussi terrien
que celui de l'Ukraine un impact
maritime qu'on le veuille ou non alors
que finalement
[Musique]
c'était pas intuitif j'allais dire au
moins au départ deuxième point les
capacités de déni d'accès les capacités
de de
d'interdiction ou de volonté
d'interdiction des espaces sont
renforcés c'est finalement l'application
maritime de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure d'une certaine façon la mère se
rétrécit aujourd'hui tout le monde a
tout le monde beaucoup de gens ont des
accès à satellites à des radars à des
drones on a des missiles anti navire qui
seront proliférés et qui vont de plus en
plus loin on a des mines moi je
commandais le Jean Bart pendant
l'opération baliste au Liban en 2006 et
le Hezbollah avait des missiles chinois
qui étaient des copies de missiles
occidentaux de Harpoon s'appelait c8002
moi c'est le Jean-Bart c'était le
fleuron de la marine française à
l'époque en défense aérienne et bien on
était à équivalence avec le Hezbollah le
Hezbollah qui tirait un missile à partir
de camions qui étaient sur le parking de
l'aéroport de Beyrouth et et quand on
regardait la balance technologique de
nos de nos moyens on était déjà ce que
j'ai observé moi j'ai vécu avec le
Hezbollah aujourd'hui c'est généralisé
et ça c'est un vrai sujet les espaces
sont contestés de plus en plus donc
notre supériorité relative diminue
et notamment
à partir de la terre la marine c'est une
armée technique donc c'est vrai que ça
limitait normalement l'accès à l'action
en mer pour les pays qui n'étaient pas
trop de haute technologie 1 avec la
mondialisation la tous ces pays ont
monté
en technologie ça c'est l'effet de la et
deux comme les armes portent plus loin
et qu'on voit plus loin avec les
satellites les drones etc on peut tirer
plus loin à partir de la terre donc il y
a même pas besoin d'avoir de frégate
pour vous empêcher de vous rapprocher de
la Terre avec des bateaux et ça c'est
quand même un fait complètement nouveau
et je vais préciser un peu plus un peu
plus loin donc nos bateaux sont donc de
plus en plus vulnérables en particulier
sur des mers rétrécies
donc alors c'est foutu non je crois pas
d'abord ça remet en tête ça remet en
place la notion de marine océanique
c'est-à-dire que autant grenouiller en
Méditerranée beaucoup de gens savent
faire allez au milieu de l'océan Indien
pour être capable de comprendre ce qui
se passe à des centaines de kilomètres
de chez vous pour pouvoir de votre
bateau pour pouvoir savoir ce qui se
passe et intervenir militairement loin
alors que vous êtes au milieu de l'océan
Indien donc on a vu l'érabilité en tout
cas en dehors de portée de ce que je
viens de dire ça ça devient important
donc aujourd'hui moi je vous le dis
enfin là pour le coup à la fois enfin
sous mes trois casquettes j'allais dire
il me semble qu'avoir une capacité
océanique
océanique de haute mer capable de durer
loin et longtemps au milieu de l'océan
Indien au milieu de l'Atlantique au
milieu du Pacifique ça devient vital
parce que ceux qui se rapprocheront
auront
des difficultés auront des difficultés
après il y a la mobilité
par définition ça tue les gens et ça
coule des bateaux et qu'un bateau de
guerre il est amené à couler et quand un
bateau coule c'est 80 100 personnes 300
personnes qui meurent le beldrano
c'était 400 personnes et pendant la
guerre du malwin le bateau argentin
croisé argentin qui était torpillé par
un sous-marin un sous-marin anglais les
Anglais ont perdu plus d'une vingtaine
de bateaux pendant la guerre et moi qui
commandait des bateaux qui fait beaucoup
de défense aériennes je disais à mes
équipages les trois bateaux anglais de
défense aérienne qui sont descendus avec
l'amiral boudoir au malin les trois on
n'ont pas fini la guerre ils ont été
soit coulés soit tellement endommagés
qu'ils ont dû être remplacés par trois
autres bon ce qui pose un problème avec
la marine française qui n'a jamais eu
que quatre bateaux de défense aériennes
de de depuis des années 60 jamais plus
de 4 donc je pense que c'est des
questions qu'il faut se poser
aujourd'hui véritablement un bateau ça
coule et donc un équipage ça peut mourir
et ça fait partie de l'équation je pense
qu'il faut et là ça devient beaucoup
plus politique donc je pense que vous
êtes en première ligne il faut envisager
de temps en temps de taper le premier
parce qu'on rentre dans une autre
logique un monde de conflits avant dans
les années 90 2000 le monde était a
priori Pacifique les armées étaient là
en maintien de l'or dans quelques sortes
dans une logique un peu de CRS
internationale si je puisse exprimer
comme ça aujourd'hui dans un monde de
conflictualité ou tout le monde tape sur
tout le monde sans aucune inhibition
donc il faut se poser la question de
savoir est-ce qu'on veut prendre
systématiquement le premier coup sachant
que le premier coup peut-être mortel
pour nous est-ce que c'est crédible non
donc il faut envisager au moins la
possibilité de taper le premier et puis
ce que je reviens sur l'idée mais je
veux pas aller plus loin les menaces de
rétorsion être capable de dire ok je
rentre dans un coupe-gorge je sais que
je suis sous ta menace mais j'ai les
capacités de frappe à posteriori de
rétorsion
tellement forte que je ne te conseille
pas de venir couler mon bateau ma
frégate mon porte-avion et les petites
mères alors là je vais aller directement
danser dans l'autre sens évidemment
voilà on a fait une étude à la FM es sur
la territorialisation des mers je vais
la territorialisation des mers ce
phénomène qui qui est qui va plus loin
que ce que j'ai évoqué la capacité
d'action militaire je vous l'ai dit vers
la mer mais la capacité de compréhension
et puis l'exploitation progressive du
droit de la mère à des fins
d'appropriation de la mer tout ça
s'explique il n'y a pas que du
machiavélisme la géopolitique bien sûr
d'Arsen d'ailleurs ça mais aussi du
culturel et puis continentaux n'ont pas
la même relation à l'espace que les pays
maritimes etc je pourrais développer si
vous le souhaitez mais pour nous
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire les zones en
orange foncées c'est les zones sur
lesquelles il y a un vrai problème de
liberté des maires dans les années à
venir donc vous voyez la Méditerranée
orientale la mer Rouge le golf
arabo-persique sont des mers la mère de
Chine du Sud bien sûr sont des mers qui
pourraient être nous être totalement pas
totalement mais qui serait dangereuse
pour nos bateaux dangereuses pour nos
bateaux et quand vous avez en orange
clair c'est les zones
dans lequel il peut y avoir des
problèmes en tout cas on peut être
largement challengé sur notre sur la
propriétaire par l'appropriation des
autres des maires qui sont plus dont on
a l'usage
or donc ça pose une question très forte
c'est si on doit d'abord on est un pays
très particulier on a des drones comme
et dans le mot est pas le bon parce que
je dis on a des drones comme si c'était
une possession nous sommes des dromes
comme nous sommes un pays archipel
archipelagique nous sommes
nous sommes un pays du Sud d'ailleurs
nous sommes un pays
qui existe en dehors de la de l'Europe
et ben donc là la cape à notre capacité
à protéger notre pays éloigné de
l'Europe
n'est pas un luxe c'est vital c'est
vital
et donc l'accès à la Réunion par exemple
comme vous pouvez le voir si vous vous
dites que Suez est fermé ou que la mer
Rouge est fermée ou que le Méditerranée
fermée ou en tout cas pas assuré pas
assuré
il faut faire le tour c'est pas
dramatique on peut le faire c'est 7
jours de merde de plus mais dans ces
cas-là ça se prépare ça veut dire qu'il
faut des points d'appui ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut être sûr de pouvoir
avoir par exemple à Dakar avoir
maintenir des relations avec avec le
Sénégal pour avoir la possibilité il
faut peut-être penser à un Angola Luanda
ou ailleurs un autre point d'appui etc
tout ça s'anticipe il faut avoir
suffisamment de bateau de moyens pour
protéger nos dômes comme notre Drom com
en cas d'agression en cas de de oui de
problématiques non seulement sur leur
souveraineté mais sur leur sécurité
il faut avoir suffisamment de bateau de
déployer en permanence pour que les les
renforts n'arrivent pas trop tard
n'arrive pas comme la cavalerie après
après la bataille etc etc donc tout ça
se pense et c'est un énorme enjeu et
c'est la conséquence de cette de cette
vulnérabilité croissante de nos moyens
et
alors donc j'en viens à ma conclusion
ma conclusion c'est quoi la France est
un pays est une puissance moyenne qui
est en recul relatif la puissance est
quelque chose de relatif c'est pas
absolu
et qui a une qui a des spécificités donc
il y a une espèce de une forme de
singularité stratégique nous sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes pas
comme les autres et pas simplement à
cause de l'édition nucléaire non non
nous ne sommes pas comme les autres ne
serait-ce qu'à cause de notre homme
alors soit on considère que notre
drumcom sont des restes de l'empire
colonial ce que la moitié de l'ONU pense
et que tout le monde veut nous faire
croire et que et les Européens
d'ailleurs de la même façon et dans ces
et on se prépare intellectuellement à
dire ok tout ça on n'est pas à l'aise
avec ça on lâche tout bon ok à ce
moment-là on rentre dans la norme dans
plein de domaines et on devient comme
des Italiens les Allemands les Espagnols
enfin bon très bien on devient un petit
européen normal soit on considère que
c'est parti intégrante de la France de
l'identité française de ce que c'est de
ce que nous voulons représenter aux face
au monde et dans ces cas-là nous avons
une singularité mais il faut il faut
l'assumer c'est une singularité
exceptionnelle moi j'ai fait des
relations internationales militaires
pendant des années aucun pays européen
ne comprend ça aucun pays européen ne
comprend ça sauf peut-être les
Britanniques mais qui font semblant de
pas comprendre pour nous embêter parce
que ils sont mais les gens ne nous
comprennent pas
parce que nous sommes à part nous sommes
autonomes et dans ces cas là il faut pas
simplement le dire il faut que ça
participe de notre politique là je pense
que vous êtes
l'enceinte la mieux la mieux apte à
comprendre cet enjeu-là mon avis c'est
un enjeu et derrière ça si on découle si
la réponse est oui c'est la France alors
tout le reste vient derrière quand vous
voyez ce que je viens de vous dire notre
territoire national du Sud qu'on peut
l'appeler comme ça ça fait un peu
provocateur nous sommes un pays du Sud
notre territoire national du Sud et
vulnérable et menacé
et nous serons attaqués de l'intérieur
de l'extérieur de partout en fait à
l'ONU par le droit par par l'économie
par l'appropriation des ressources n'est
pas simplement ça par
une déstabilisation interne que ça soit
sur le territoire hexagonal ou sur notre
ou sur ces territoires nos territoires
d'outre-mer donc je répète on est une
puissance faible on a une puissance
originale et quand on est faible
original et qu'on veut marquer cette son
ambition et bien il faut avoir une il
faut être proactif il faut être il faut
accepter la prise de risque parce que le
risque la le repli le repli frileux la
ligne Maginot on peut gagner 15 ans mais
on perd à la fin on perd à la fin moi
j'en suis convaincu militairement et
politiquement et même probablement
philosophiquement je suis toujours
frappé par exemple je donne je donne
l'exemple enfin quelque chose qui me
frappe en tant que militaire c'est
Israël un pays qui depuis sa naissance
est condamné à mourir à échéance assez
courte et un pays qui continue à peser
je portais de mon sujet n'est pas Israël
aujourd'hui mais ce qui me caractérise
c'est que comment un pays aussi faible
structurellement dans les paramètres
sont aussi négatifs arrivent à non
seulement à survivre mais à défendre ses
intérêts avec pas mal de brio finalement
parce qu'il est extrêmement proactif il
passe son temps à remettre en cause à
revoir réanalyser apprendre des risques
apprendre des risques il est
certainement un peu inconfortable plus à
plus plus confort plus inconfortable que
que si on est tranquille dans sa petite
casemate mais c'est un peu comme la
sécurité active dans les voitures la
sécurité passive vous voyez la sécurité
active c'est plus efficace et bien je
pense que un pays faible comme le nôtre
enfin qui s'affaiblit objectivement
relatif par rapport à aux puissances
montantes et qui a une telle spécificité
qui veut maintenir sa vision sa force
son intérêt etc il ne peut pas ne pas
être proactif et prendre des risques et
ça ça au départ des risques des risques
évidemment politiques donc pas de repli
pas d'alignement tout bête parce que
c'est extrêmement réducteur et que
toutes nos spécificités toute notre
singularité stratégique serait annivée
parce qu'elle est elle est niée par tous
les autres
parce que on est spéciaux
donc il faut algir au loin en amont de
manière multiforme et voyez bien là il y
a un enjeu maritime c'est pour ça que je
veux pas aller beaucoup plus loin c'est
tellement évident
il faut diversifier les partenariats
bien sûr nous sommes occidentaux nous
sommes dans la culture dans la politique
et géographiquement la France
métropolitaine étant et dans l'Occident
donc il y a une solidarité occidentale
évidemment qui se discute pas et la
menace que fait peser par exemple les
pays de l'Est pour dire le front de
l'Est que Russie Chine sur l'Occident
elle ne concerne directement donc il y a
pas il y a pas de question avec ça mais
bien sûr nous sommes aussi européens
nous avons une solidarité avec nos
voisins européens mais nous sommes aussi
du Sud nous sommes aussi autre et je
pense que il faut et donc nos relations
bilatérales avec les pays les autres
pays du Sud qui ont été toujours été un
peu la force de la France et que nous
avons un petit peu perdu au profit de
nos solidarités Nord
occidentale européenne qui sont tout à
fait légitimes je pense que là il y a il
y a quelque chose à voir surtout dans le
monde qui bouge aujourd'hui avec le
poids que le sud prend et la
vulnérabilité a notamment en Afrique que
j'ai évoqué il y a un problème de
perception bon je veux pas aller
beaucoup plus loin militairement il faut
être capable de faire la différence donc
l'additionnant nucléaire la différence
conventionnelle j'en ai parlé
aggloméré la technologie et la masse et
puis se poser la question de la
protection de la France France en
métropole France dans les DROM com pour
des attaques sous le seuil car il y a un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une
une vue de l'esprit on peut on peut être
attaqué et pour la marine il faut de la
développer de l'interopérabilité des
points d'appui etc bon je finis parce
que sinon je donc trois idées forces le
sud est extrêmement important c'est
vital pour nous et nous en faisons
partie la singularité française nous
avons une singularité stratégique et qui
qui entraîne une maritimité et nous
sommes une nation maritime des facto
voilà merci de votre attention
très bien merci beaucoup amiral pour
cette présentation particulièrement
riche et dynamique je crois que tous les
collègues ont apprécié alors nous allons
passer aux questions si vous voulez bien
j'ai deux séries de 5 alors la première
personne qui va intervenir c'est
Catherine qui est également rapporteur
du pour le moment Méditerrané enfin nous
expliquer tout ça donc Catherine qui va
commencer et après il y aura quatre
interventions avant de passer le
deuxième paquet merci monsieur le
Président amiral merci en tout cas de
nous de faire profiter notre commission
des travaux d'autres fines tank c'est
vrai que nous avions eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec Isabelle Raymond pavéro
dans le cadre du rapport que nous avions
produits sur le réarmement Méditerranée
d'ailleurs vous avez bien insisté et je
pense que c'est important
sur le danger de se réarmement qui
généralise et qui quelque part
en fait l'ensemble des pays c'est la
propriété ou presque donc d'où le
vous nous aviez expliqué aussi que le
bassin méditerranéen est une véritable
poudrière et on nous avait dit qu'un
conflit mondial de haute intensité
pouvait éclater dans cette zone à tout
moment
tout récemment nous avons reçu ici dans
le cadre de cette commission
l'ambassadeur de Turquie en France dans
une audition qui était d'ailleurs pas
qui nous a pas forcément rassuré je
pense que je peux dire ça pour
l'ensemble des collègues je voulais
savoir si dans le cadre de vos travaux
vous pouviez nous dire où on est
exactement la situation dans cette zone
les tensions Méditerranée orientales et
notamment avec évidemment ce rôle de de
la Turquie qui sort de son cadre de
médiateur comme elle le dit mais qui est
un acteur important
dans le cadre du conflit russeau
ukrainien et également par rapport à la
Grèce et aussi à Chypre donc ça c'est ma
première question puis je voudrais
également vous avez abordé le sujet de
l'Afrique
avec certains collègues nous étions en
audition sur un rétexte de barkham
on nous a beaucoup parlé et c'est un
sujet qui revient beaucoup de la
désinformation en Afrique je crois que
c'est très important et le récit des
Russes notamment sur la décadence des
puissances occidentales
semblent efficace malheureusement dans
un certain nombre de pays d'Afrique
est-ce que vous avez une réflexion sur
ces sujets qui nous donne dirait quels
moyens il faut mettre en place si les
moyens que nous avons mis en place
actuellement sont suffisent ne sont pas
suffisants et il semble que il faille
mettre en place des moyens plus
importants merci beaucoup merci
Catherine deuxième question Joël Joël
guerriot
merci Président on peut revenir sur la
carte précédente qui présente la
planisphère
on se concentrant voilà celle-ci
non non
celle-ci je la trouve très intéressantes
et la présentation que vous avez faite
était intéressante cette notion estos ça
permet en plus de mettre en lumière la
Méditerranée et de voir plus
particulièrement la position d'Ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment au cœur de
nos de nos réflexions et de nos de nos
préoccupations et on voit par cette
carte là la position stratégique de la
Turquie qui finalement tient le passage
vers la mer Noire avec le Bosphore qui
fait 32 km
j'aimerais votre point de vue sur la
présence maritime sur la Méditerranée
sur ce que l'entre le la Turquie et bien
ambitionne dans le cas du contrôle
justement de cette
je dirais de cette partie entre l'Europe
et puis l'Asie et donc comment on peut
sur le plan stratégique évoluer ou égard
aux ambitions d'Ankara dans cette dans
cet environnement j'aimerais bien
entendre sur ce sujet et puis j'aimerais
aussi
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure il y a un point là qui qui m'a
marqué c'est la vulnérabilité de notre
marine de la Terre avec des armes de
précision nouveau j'aimerais savoir quel
conséquences ça peut avoir à l'aube de
cette volonté que nous avons affirmé
d'avoir un nouveau
porte-avions nucléaire
qu'elle serait sa fragilité dans ce cas
là et quel type de marine doit-on mettre
en oeuvre demain pour ce pour se
renforcer entre guillemets face à cette
à ce risque parce que si on met un
comment un porte-avion avec
l'investissement que ça représente pour
notre pays sur le sur l'eau et qu'il est
vulnérable on peut se poser bien des
questions donc comment mieux protéger
faut-il en avoir deux trois quatre je
crois pas qu'on en est des moyens donc
comment va-t-on se sortir merci Joël
alors je passe la parole à marie-arlet
Carlotti oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci pour votre
très large intervention oui nous le
savons la Méditerranée est un lieu de
toutes les fractures économique sociale
religieuse et on n'oublie pas que chaque
année des milliers de personnes meurent
sur en Méditerranée et des corps
d'enfants arrivent sur nos rivages qui
est particulièrement dramatique et
intolérable en plus désormais vous
l'avez bien dit la question de sécurité
on sait bien que les menaces sont là du
haut conséquences de la guerre d'Ukraine
conséquence du terrorisme mais pour nous
la Méditerranée c'est aussi autre chose
c'est-à-dire notre marée Nostrum vous
disiez tout à l'heure la mer se rétrécit
pour nous elle a toujours été très
étroite car il y a des liens ancestraux
de part et d'autre de la rive de la
Méditerranée et ma question est là
aujourd'hui je trouve que l'Europe n'a
pas de politique volontaire volontariste
en direction du sud
j'avais eu beaucoup d'espoir à l'époque
sur le processus de Barcelone qui a
travers les programmes MEDA même si ils
ont été remis en cause créé des liens
entre les sociétés civiles entre les
collectivités territoriales puisque vous
travaillez là-dessus et entre les
parlements et aujourd'hui nous sommes
avec ma collègue elle vient de partir
mais elle est là Sylvie gouachement nous
sommes membres au nom du Sénat de
l'Assemblée parlementaire pour la
Méditerranée et on se sent bien seul
parce que non appuyez sur une politique
européenne qui nous aiderait à avoir une
voix commune donc ma question c'est en
tant que la fmes qui travaille sur des
études est-ce que vous avez orienté
certaines études sur une nouvelle
politique en Méditerranée parce que la
politique de voisinage qui a remplacé
tout le reste précédemment dilu un peu
le regard qu'à la robe sur la
Méditerranée
merci Muriel Arlette je pose la parole
Olivier sigoulotti merci Monsieur le
vice-président amiral en vous remerciant
pour votre présentation je souhaiterais
pour ma part revenir sur cette notion de
de différence et de divergences avec
avec ce Sud que vous avez parfaitement
décrit et parfaitement nommé notamment
avec les divergences de notre continent
et le continent africain la Méditerranée
est devenue un point de passage
migratoire important entre ce Sud et
l'Europe
est-ce qu'on peut se limiter aujourd'hui
contenu du risque de conflictualité que
vous avez abordé est-ce qu'on peut se
limiter aux conséquences c'est-à-dire
renforcer les moyens de Frontex ou
est-ce qu'à un moment on ne sera pas
dans l'obligation de de réinterroger
notre politique publique d'aide au
développement avec ce continent africain
dont on connaît l'évolution notamment
démographique mais également économique
merci amiral
merci Olivier la parole est à Pierre
Laurent pierre
merci amiral et merci pour votre
présentation très très intéressante et
stimulante
je veux faire une remarque et poser deux
questions voilà la première remarque
c'est que votre constat de départ
que je trouve personnellement très
intéressant et très pertinent
devrait à mes yeux
du conduire à une interrogation
plus large que la seule question
militaire parce que pour réduire
l'immensité des fractures de la
fragmentation du monde dont vous parlez
en posant la question du Sud comme vous
la posez évidemment on voit bien que
l'unique réponse militaire à cette
question
sera peut être structurellement
suffisante et je dirais même que si
c'était l'unique ou c'était si c'était
la charpente de toute notre réponse elle
pourrait même devenir structurellement
dangereuse en tout cas ça c'est mon avis
donc je pense que on devrait
penser
toujours et à fortiori à cause du
constat que vous faites la dimension
militaire de nos stratégie articulée à
une stratégie de sécurité globale que
moi j'appelle le sécurité globale et qui
déborde largement immunitaire ce que ce
que nous ne ce que nous ne faisons pas à
mes yeux pour le moment mais là c'est
pas une question qui s'adresse seulement
à vous c'est une remarque que m'inspire
votre exposé après j'ai deux questions
précises il y en a une qui vient d'être
évoquées par Joël guerrillot c'est à
quoi sert dans votre concept dans la
conception vous venez de développer un
porte-avion puisque là le président de
la République a puisque semble-t-il il y
avait un peu une discussion sur ce point
annoncer dans son discours le
renouvellement d'un porte-avions donc à
quoi sert un porte-avions dans cette
stratégie
et ma deuxième question elle concerne
plus directement l'Ukraine
les il y a beaucoup de lignes rouges qui
sont en train de sauter
sur les questions de soutien à l'Ukraine
et je pense qu'on peut aller vers des
d'autres lignes rouges qui sont trop
est-ce que vous pensez qu'une un
objectif militaire de reconquête de
l'Ukraine de la Crimée par la force
comment est-ce que vous
amiral vous pensez cette question là
puisque la Crimée je vous pose la
question sur la Crimée parce que la
Crimée ces enjeux sont
seraient inévitablement maritime aussi
puisque c'est une place forte maritime
et notamment avec
Sébastopol donc comment et au dessin
comment est-ce que vous vous pensez
crédible cet objectif militaire je dis
pas qu'il est aujourd'hui mis sur la
table de cette manière là mais à la
vitesse à laquelle on avance c'est une
question qui pourrait être assez
rapidement posée comment est-ce que vous
vous envisageriez cette question là
merci merci Pierre mammiral paroles est
à vous pour la première série de
questions merci et merci Monsieur
président
la première j'ai commencé par parler de
l'Afrique et qui recouvre tout ce qui a
été dit sur à la fois la rupture la
guerre internationale
donc il y a barkhane il y a il y a aussi
ce rapport entre l'Afrique et l'Europe
et donc Marino strum etc bon je
d'abord je redise parce que c'est je
pense que c'est clé et c'est vrai que
pour nous pour nous en tout cas pour ma
génération c'est quand même quelque
chose de compliqué parce que on nous
sommes face à une situation une
évolution du monde qui n'est pas celle
que nous attendions voilà je pense qu'il
faut être capable de d'être lucide la
génération avant nous on connu entre les
deux guerres ce dilemme terrible de voir
un réel moment de l'Allemagne qui était
pas du tout ce qu'ils attendaient et
c'était même ce qui détestent qu'ils et
ils ont eu beaucoup de mal et Marc bloc
a très bien écrit la difficulté
intellectuelle que ça représentait pour
tous les citoyens et pour les politiques
de de d'avoir cette lucidité le monde
que nous avons n'est pas celui que nous
attendions nous attendions une
européanisation du monde et notamment de
l'Afrique bon et donc cette marée
Nostrum elle devenait naturellement
Nostrum en l'occurrence c'est plus du
tout une marinostrum chacun
chaque jour est un peu plus fragmenté
c'est un fait
on peut se poser la question de savoir
la vie est-ce que ça peut durer et
pacifiquement je ne le crois pas si la
divergence entre le Nord et le Sud
s'accroît cette incompréhension mutuelle
s'accroît le ressentiment va s'accroître
les différences de démographie vont
s'accroître les différences de
potentialité de violence mutuelle vont
être enfin évidemment je pense que c'est
on peut pas continuer comme ça le
statuko n'est pas une option bon le
deuxième point donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors
première réflexe on se ferme
la forteresse la ligne Maginot après
tout on fait comme si la Méditerranée
avait 8000 km de large et puis c'est
plutôt moi je pense que c'est pas une
solution si Israël avait fait ça il
serait mort depuis longtemps et chaque
fois que dans l'histoire une une
puissance un pays a cru pouvoir
préserver son lannir face à un
environnement hostile en se barricadant
et ben ça peut durer ça ralentit les les
échéances mais ça ne règle pas les
problèmes de fond donc
troisième option bah voilà c'est notre
tour on a perdu on a bien profité on a
plus qu'à mourir donc on espère on ne se
dilue en quelque sorte dans une espèce
de la fin c'est l'histoire je pense pas
que ce soit une option non plus l'être
humain aura le droit à survivre et ses
petits-enfants ont le droit à essayer de
vivre dans dans dans un environnement à
la fois qu'il aurait propice et qui est
stable et sécurisé en paix donc à mon
avis ni
ni le pont-levis qu'on relève ni les
grandes la porte grande ouverte parce
que c'est c'est la disparition il y a un
sujet majeur il faut accepter simplement
qu'on a face à nous un continent qui est
en forte croissance qui a un modèle qui
n'est pas le nôtre
acceptez donc déjà la diversité des
modèles l'altérité des modèles
prendre acte du fait que nous partons
avec des différencies économiques de
développement absolument considérable
que l'aide au développement d'anti a été
évoquée
risible par rapport aux besoins donc il
y a un transfert de richesse majeur à
effectuer transfert de richesse qui ne
veut pas dire que les qu'on demande donc
il y a une question sur la
conditionnalité c'est sûr que si on
donne des milliards et des dizaines de
milliards et qui se retrouvent tous en
Suisse c'est pas l'objet donc il y a une
conditionnalité quand même à respecter
mais pas nécessairement demander à nos
voisins du sud de se transformer en
européen en petits européens moi je suis
j'étais frappé par Kaboul comme tout le
monde je pense on est passé 20 ans à
Kaboul en Afghanistan j'ai été plusieurs
reprises dans mes fonctions
il y a pas eu un coup de feu quand les
talibans sont entrés dans Kaboul il y a
pas eu un coup de feu après au bout de
20 ans au bout de 20 ans parce que
finalement le modèle qu'on leur
proposait globalement
t'as pas été suffisamment attractif pour
que la population entre le modèle
Taliban et le modèle occidental se
battent pour garder moduleusement il n'y
a pas eu un seul coup de feu rien à voir
avec l'Ukraine la Russie et l'Ukraine
et bien ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
l'accepter c'était peut-être une c'est
peut-être une blessure narcissique pour
nous les Européens ça veut pas dire que
notre système est pas et pas bon moi je
suis ravi d'être ici et pas simplement
parce qu'on y vit bien je pense qu'on a
on a un modèle intellectuel
philosophique etc qui est propre qui a
sa richesse qui a sa noblesse qui est
qui a d'ailleurs fasciné le monde
pendant des des décennies et voir des
siècles mais aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il
a il a peut-être
hyper perfectible et puis en tout cas il
n'est plus aussi fascinant qu'avant donc
notre rapport à l'Afrique
c'est un rapport qui doit remettre à
plat
qui remettra plat tous les l'équations
c'est évidemment pas que militaire c'est
c'est
aussi dans les représentations mais je
pense qu'on ferait fausse route à croire
simplement que par exemple c'est que les
Russes la propagande russe qui qui fait
que les qu'on est en train de perdre
l'Afrique parce qu'on est en train
littéralement de perdre l'Afrique et ça
c'est quand même majeur c'est majeur
parce que l'Afrique est à nos portes et
que nous avons des liens des diaspora
croiser phénoménal comment peut-on
imaginer que au Mali tout le monde
conspu la France depuis l'âge de 5 ans
jusqu'à
même si c'est pas encore complètement le
cas en tout cas comment peut-on imaginer
que ça l'ADN et que tout se passe bien
chez nous c'est juste pas possible et
donc et c'est pas normal on doit pas
être conspué comme je vais vous donner
un exemple très concret moi je trouve
que je fais entendre des conférences de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée dans des
enceintes plutôt militaires donc des
gens qui en Tunisie avec des gens qu'on
connaît bien et que lequel on s'entend
très bien avec lequel on a beaucoup
d'affinités en fait beaucoup d'affinités
car nous sommes aussi un pays du Sud et
nous Français je parle et bien
j'ai bien senti depuis quelques années
une
perception très différente de gens de
gens qui pourtant nous connaissent bien
etc et qui nous connaissent de moins en
moins et qui nous comprennent de moins
en moins etc donc il y a il y a aussi
une guerre une guerre des
représentations mais il n'y a pas que ça
et je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça mais c'est en tout cas
on peut pas ne pas dans mon avis traiter
le traité le sujet voilà pour la partie
africaine et
et
tout ce qui va autour je voudrais vous
montrer une carte
non c'est dans l'autre sens
là elle vous intéressera elle parlera de
la Méditerranée orientale dans cette
carte n'est pas de nous elle est d'une
cartographie marseillaise elle a
l'avantage de présenter la Méditerranée
par le vue du Levant
dans un sens tous les sens sont bons il
y a pas de bon sens en fait mais en tout
cas stimulante intellectuellement
stimulante intellectuellement pour nous
puisqu'elle nous décentre et elle voit
la Méditerranée vu des deux puissances
dont on a évoqué et donc la Russie et la
Turquie qui sont des puissances
continentales qui sont des puissances
enclavées et quand elle voit la
Méditerranée leur accès aux océans qui
est l'accès à la mer qui est l'accès au
commerce qui est l'accès maintenant à
des richesses puisque maintenant on peut
forer et trouver des des ressources très
profondes ce qu'on pouvait pas le faire
avant et bien et qu'on est russe ou turc
on se dit que l'accès à Gibraltar est
quand même compliqué dès que les choses
sont un peu conflictuelles c'est un
goulet un goulot d'étranglement et
passer le canal de Sicile
vous passez pas très bien donc votre
accès il est par Suez
donc pour vous
ce qui est clé c'est tenir la
Méditerranée orientale alors quand vous
êtes ru c'est tenir la mer Noire parce
que c'est pas la doute n'est pas la mer
Noire vous n'arrivez pas à la méditer à
orientale et encore moins un Suez et
encore moins à l'océan donc un tenir la
mer Noire 2 quand vous êtes russe vous
arrangez avec les Turcs pour passer par
les droitures parce que sinon vous êtes
bloqué donc vous avez toujours on aura
toujours un accord entre Erdogan et
Poutine et le successeur d'Erdogan fera
pas exception si on a un
entre la Turquie et la Russie il y aura
toujours un accord car c'est essentiel
pour la Russie alors on pourrait dire
bah oui mais les Turcs c'est moins
essentiel pour eux oui mais les Russes
sont suffisamment de leviers sur la
Turquie pour les obliger à négocier un
accord il suffira d'aider un peu les
Kurdes et hop immédiatement vous savez
c'est un sujet extrêmement brûlant
extrêmement brûlant pour la Turquie mais
là quand on voit ça on comprend pourquoi
la Méditerranée orientale va devenir un
espèce de enfin un espace qui sera
extrêmement contesté dans lequel la
Turquie et la Russie seront extrêmement
présentes
c'est pas une très bonne nouvelle pour
l'Egypte parce que l'Egypte elle vit
aussi beaucoup de transit européen qui
passe par par celui et puis là il y a il
y a un péage or le péage il est calculé
juste pour être un petit peu moins cher
que de faire le tour donc s'il y a un
moment ça devient trop dangereux que les
primes d'assurance deviennent trop trop
élevé pour aller pour travailler pour
aller en Méditerranée orientale et bien
les gens font le tour c'est un peu plus
c'est 7 jours de merde de plus 7 à 10
jours c'est un bateau par ligne de
commercial qui relie la Chine à l'Europe
c'est pas c'est pas hors de prix
c'est-à-dire c'est faisable donc pour
les par contre pour l'Égypte
catastrophique donc c'est là qu'on voit
que l'Egypte sera toujours de notre côté
de notre côté pour préserver la liberté
des mères et l'accès le plus sécurisé
possible mais c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet et c'est un sujet militaire et je
reviens à la politique turque
quand on est turc moi je crois si
j'étais chef de la Major de la marine
turque tu comprendrais assez bien la
maladie vatane et la politique turque
qui dit je suis un pays continental
autour de moi j'ai des îlots grecs à
quelques kilomètres de Madame à côte qui
m'empêche d'accéder librement à la haute
mer finalement et donc j'ai un bon c'est
très c'est très désagréable mais après
que si on regarde l'histoire tout ça est
logique hein c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la
côte la côte d'Anatolie du littoral
était grec depuis depuis Homère donc
depuis 3000 ans donc au départ c'était
c'était grec il se trouve que que après
le le entre le traité de Sèvres et le
Traité de Lausanne on a chassé les Grecs
et puis on a d'ailleurs les Turcs qui
étaient en Grèce se sont sont chassés de
graisse aussi et on fait on a fait une
forme de nettoyage ethnique qui fait que
maintenant la côte turque est
véritablement turque et comme à l'époque
tout le monde se fichait de ses petites
îles parce qu'il y a pas de pétrole
parce que tout le monde et puis que la
Turquie est un pays continental qui pour
qui qui est important c'était c'était la
Turquie
continentale
Moustafa qui est mal se fiché
complètement et donc elle essaie les
îles Grecs alors maintenant ça devient
un sujet et alors le Shelter majorne et
je pense que l'ambassadeur a dû montrer
des cartes qui montrent en disant
comment se fait-il que la mer Égée soit
une mère grecque alors que nous sommes
ça devrait être au moins à moitié-moitié
mais ça donc le problème c'est qu'en
Turquie et là aussi on parle dans la
représentation et bien tout le monde
connaît le Traité de Lausanne tout le
monde connaît de traiter de Sèvres tout
le monde a été élevé dans l'idée que les
Occidentaux humilié la Turquie à la
chute de l'Empire ottoman un peu comme
en
Chine avec les traités inégaux tous les
petits enfants apprennent ça en propre
primaire alors qu'en France personne ne
sait ce que c'est que le Traité de
Lausanne le traité de Sèvres tout ça on
s'en fiche complètement et quand on
regarde une carte on dit c'est vrai que
c'est pas très objectif c'est pas très
équilibré entre la Grèce et la Turquie
donc une fois encore il faut comprendre
l'altérité il faut comprendre que les
Turcs aient envie d'eux c'est logique
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas choquant
on peut comprendre pourquoi c'est comme
ça et on peut le rappeler que l'histoire
n'est pas tout à fait celle qui raconte
parce que ça fait partie de l'équation
une chose est sûre la Turquie est une
puissance qui s'affirme dans la région
il y a 15 ans on aurait on aurait pas
présenté la Turquie comme une puissance
régionale majeure aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas ne pas la présenter comme la
puissance régionale majeure elle a elle
a développé des outils en plus des
outils nationaux il y a une RAM
nationalisation de l'outil militaire il
y a une vraie vision politique qui est
partagée par la population turque y
compris de toutes de tout bord y compris
à gauche donc je pense que les résultats
des élections ne va pas changer
fondamentalement la posture turque en
Méditerranée orientale elle est d'une
certaine façon très logique très logique
et cette carte le montre bon maintenant
elle pose des problèmes il faut accepter
dans ce nouveau monde où tout le monde
ne converge pas vers nous il faut aussi
accepter que les autres défendent leurs
intérêts mais il faut pas non plus se
laisser imposer la vision de l'autre
surtout manu militari c'est intolérable
donc là il faut rentrer dans un monde de
rapports de force c'est un peu c'est une
fois encore c'est pas le monde qu'on
avait prévu mais c'est le
c'est le monde tel qu'il est et la
géopolitique est de retour dernier point
sur la le porte-avion qui était posé la
question à quoi sert un porte-avion si
la mer se rétrécit justement
si vous voulez agir à partir de la mer
ou agir sur mer ou protéger nos espaces
maritimes ou protéger nos notre parti de
France qui est outre-mer et le mot
outre-mer à un sens et bien il faut
savoir que il faut pouvoir être au
milieu de l'océan il faut pouvoir être
loin des côtes il vous faut des bateaux
suffisamment grands gros pour pouvoir
s'éloigner de la menace et quand même
faire peser une menace sur sur les gens
qui vous menacent et ça et bien le
porte-avion
peut le faire et nul enfin en tout cas
peut le faire de façon absolument unique
quand vous avez un porte-avion au milieu
de l'océan Indien qui a des capacités de
frappe à des centaines de kilomètres de
voir des milliers de kilomètres de lui
et qui a alors là au milieu de l'océan
Indien il est invulnérable ou en tout
cas beaucoup beaucoup moins vulnérable
et lui par contre il peut faire peser
une menace sur les gens qui veut
voudrais vous embêter et donc ce qui est
vrai pour le porte-avion les vacances en
escorte etc donc à mon avis alors
évidemment vous mettez pas le
porte-avion dans le guet-apens dans le
couloir le corridor de la mort
dans mer Rouge vous ne le mettez que si
vous êtes sûr que votre menace de
dissuivre dissuasion votre capacité de
dissuasion conventionnelle est tellement
forte que les gens vous laisseront
passer mais sinon évidemment il est pas
fait pour ça mais il y a plein de
porte-avions et Chypre devient dans ce
cas précis vous avez compris un point
absolument clé sur plan géopolitique
parce que c'est un porte-avion européen
un submersible en Méditerranée orientale
et je pense que là il faut regarder
Chypre avec beaucoup d'attention
d'autant plus que le tiers de Chypre a
été annexé et que on pourrait avoir une
un phénomène Crimée assez facilement un
mot pour la reprise de la Crimée
c'est comme vous l'avez dit une
opération qui serait maritime or la mère
noire aujourd'hui cette partie de la mer
Noire elle est russes donc franchement
je vois pas comment on pourrait
empêcher les Russes de maîtriser
l'environnement maritime autour de la
Crimée après du coup ça peut être une
opération terrestre et c'est quand même
un goulot d’étrablement c'est
extrêmement dur et puis il y a aussi
pas la réaction de la population de la
Crimée qui était quand même une région
une des une des zones qui était la plus
partagée et dans lequel là pour le coup
il y a pas eu un coup de feu je reviens
un peu le coup de feu les gens qui sont
prêts à mourir pour leurs idées c'est
quand même un révélateur assez fort
assez fort de ce que pensent les
populations à Kaboul personne n'est mort
quand les talibans sont arrivés en
crimés personne n'est mort quand les
rues sont arrivés
naturellement constituant un enjeu et là
encore on retrouve la Méditerranée
orientale au centre de ces questions
mais dans la logique de ce départir de
se découpler de l'approvisionnement je
dirais en gaz et en pétrole de la Russie
on en train de créer de nouvelles routes
chacun va signer ses accords avec le
Qatar les Émirats et autres et on est à
nouveau dans une route cette fois-ci
est-ce sud-est ouest qui devient
également extrêmement stratégique et
quand on regarde la présence russe dans
toute la Méditerranée orientale on peut
parler de la Syrie on peut parler de
l'Est de la Libye on peut parler de
Chypre quand même ils ont accès les
bateaux militaires ont accès au port
est-ce que on n'est pas notamment dans
les nouveaux flux que nous ce que nous
construisons en alternative je dirais la
fourniture de la Russie là encore sous
la menace une dépendance on voit bien
que les gaziodiques y compris dans les
eaux de maritimes dans les zones
économique exclusif de pays européens
comme le Danemark ou la Suède ça peut
exploser
voilà est-ce que la Russie n'est pas en
train au-delà de la guerre en Ukraine et
au-delà des enjeux de la mer Noire de
jouer une partition beaucoup plus large
et beaucoup plus ancienne concernant son
poids et son influence dans la
Méditerranée orientale notamment en
contournement et en pression de l'Ouest
européen
merci André vivait de Lopez oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur amiral merci pour vos propos
c'est vrai que tout le monde le dit
l'avenir va s'écrire avec la mer
d'ailleurs l'histoire nous le prouve
bien tous les pays qui ont su se
développer par la mer ont réussi les
autres noms vous nous avez évoqué les
ultramarins
l'importance de nos départements de
l'outre-mer en nous disant que bon ben
l'Europe ne l'a pas du tout confiance
que nous étions un peu particulier mis à
part les Anglais mais ça les arrange de
faire semblant de ne pas le voir mais
qu'est-ce que vraiment nous la France et
donc nos départements de travail avons
vraiment conscience de l'importance
justement de l'outre-mer puisque l'on
dit que finalement chaque département
est un porte-avions pour nous quels sont
les moyens
que nous leur donnons
qu'ils y font pour en cas de conflit
pouvoir bien apporter l'aide que l'on
peut attendre je remercie merci Vivette
Michel Guillaume Michel merci beaucoup à
l'occasion de la visite du Premier
ministre grec le 12 septembre 2022 le
président de la République a déclaré que
la France ne laisserait s'installer au
cas des ordres en particulier en
Méditerranée orientale cette conviction
suppose que la France l'Union européenne
et l'Alliance atlantique se donne
collectivement les moyens de réinvestir
l'espace stratégique
méditerranéen pouvez-vous me dire si un
travail est engagé sur une stratégie
commune et parce que la guerre d'hier ne
sera peut-être pas la guerre de demain
pensez-vous qu'il puisse y avoir un
risque de guerre avec des armes
biologiques toxines et nucléaires
combinée ou pas avec drones cyberattaque
ou satellitaire je vous merci pour votre
avis merci Michel Gisèle Jourdain
qu'elle vienne d'être exprimé par
Vivette donc Lopez mais vous avez dit
pour compléter un peu cette question
qu'il fallait que nous soyons proactif
et il est vrai que la vulnérabilité de
certaines de nos territoires
ultramarins qui sont dans des zones
vraiment à risque par rapport donc à
l'aspect donc défensif mérite d'être
prise en compte donc si vous pouviez
développer comment vous envisagez cette
proactivité
merci Gisèle Alain joliandet
merci monsieur le Président merci amiral
pour vos propos vraiment très
intéressants qui vont bien au-delà de de
vos réflexions sur la mer
vous avez dit notamment que que notre
modèle ne pouvait pas s'imposer partout
je partage complètement ce sentiment
qu'un certain nombre de moyens mis en
oeuvre à travers le monde justement pour
tenter d'imposer notre modèle
sont peut-être mal employés j'en tire
cette cette conclusion ça peut même
légitimer d'ailleurs notre départ
d'Afghanistan vous avez dit aussi non
alignement
la France doit garder sa singularité
sont des propos de qu'on aurait pu tenir
qu'à tenu le général de Gaulle
on doit être proactif on doit taper en
premier
et
par rapport aux questions d'actualité
sur la base de ces affirmations
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment sur ce
qui se passe actuellement
dans le cadre de ce grand schéma que
vous avez décrit avec lequel je suis en
plein accord quel est votre sentiment
sur ce que la France se fait en Ukraine
en termes d'alignement
faut-il taper en premier sur les Russes
puisque vous dites il faut taper en
premier donc faut-il taper en premier
sur Urus une question
également d'actualité par rapport à la
description que vous avez aux
convictions qui sont les vôtres qu'elles
peuvent être les conséquences sur une
discussion dans le cadre de la de la loi
de programmation militaire du coup
qu'est-ce que nous devons faire par
rapport à par rapport à la situation du
monde tel que vous la décrivez merci
merci Alain Olivier Cadic Olivier
merci on parlait de l'Afrique
du côté sud la France n'a pas défendu
les démocraties en Afrique en laissant
des coups d'État se produire par exemple
au Mali au Burkina Faso et là elle y a
perdu beaucoup de crédit en acceptant
ces situations les Russes de leur côté
protègent les dictateurs à ça de Maduro
qui dépendent ensuite personnellement et
physiquement de la tutelle russe eux ils
arrivent à se maintenir or on lit
aujourd'hui dans la presse libre par
exemple au Burkina je cite au Burkina
des soutiens du président de la
Transition le capitaine Traoré appelle
au meurtre de journalistes et à des
attaques contre des organes de presse si
aujourd'hui ces nouveaux
révolutionnaires se sont investis de la
mission messianique de libérer le
Burkina des intellectuels apatrides et
des chiens de la France il donne à ses
supers citoyens qui au nom de leur
liberté d'expression s'arrochent tous
les droits y compris celui de choisir
ceux qui méritent de vivre ou non des
raisons supplémentaires de poursuivre
dans leurs errements pensez-vous que la
France à la capacité de renverser des
gouvernements militaire par la force
pour imposer des élections que ça puisse
être un scénario qui crée un électrochoc
pour démontrer que la France soit en
capacité de protéger les démocrates en
Afrique merci Olivier et le petit
dernier Rachid est mal Rachid c'est pour
toi merci c'est une question de taille
non mais juste moi il y a deux points
d'abord sur l'Afrique je suis passé cap
ou pas mais en fait bon
vous avez votre approche elle est quand
même très sûr en fait il se leur seul
possibilité de se déterminer serait par
rapport à la France à l'Europe je crois
qu'il faut surtout en sortir et dire
Olivier il y a des fois on est d'accord
là je suis en désaccord enfin bon
d'abord si la France avait soutenu que
des démocraties en Afrique ça se saurait
voilà et donc je pense que sur la
question du contenu africain il y a 55
états et on peut pas de reprocher à des
états d'avoir comment mission se
développer de choisir le modèle de
développement que ça nous plaise ça ne
plaise pas via le rapport à l'Afrique un
peu plus compliqué que juste on vient
leur il y a une histoire qui parfois
très douloureuse si faut pas l'entendre
et comprendre ça voilà et on a aussi
doux la France quel que soit ses
couleurs poétiques on a aussi protégé
des Allemands qui étaient pas très voilà
donc on peut pas demander aussi au
peuple de dire je veux des choses et
c'est vrai qu'on laisse d'autres
puissances qu'on laisse sur d'autres
puissances viennent mais elles font plus
ou moins durement des choses qu'on a
déjà fait donc là aussi ne soyons pas
nous les anges et puis il y aura que les
méchants et pourtant je condamne ce que
font et les Chinois et les Russes
aujourd'hui là aussi donc faisons
attention et je pense que le sujet n'est
pas d'abord le financement l'AFD je
trouve je suis d'accord je suis avec une
souris rapporteur la relation c'est que
le transfert de technologie le problème
le jour on le fait bah le monde il
change beaucoup plus vite qu'on le pense
c'est ça le vrai sujet donc là aussi il
doit aussi nous-même on n'est pas les
gentils il y aura que la méchante ça sur
le premier point donc moi sur l'Afrique
je crois que je suis assez perturbé par
votre approche après il y a un autre
élément sur nos territoires d'outre-mer
etc excusez-moi eux ils ont conscience
d'être au milieu de de la mer et au
milieu de difficultés c'est plutôt de
chez nous qu'on a un problème d'ailleurs
nous avons fait une stratégie on le
premier rapport à quelques-uns la
stratégie française elle n'a pas été ils
n'ont pas été associés et le vrai sujet
parce que dans les cartes c'est surtout
que le centre du monde ait pu la mettait
orientale c'est très important mais
c'est l'Indopacifique et que nous sommes
nous dans la grande périphérie la grande
banlieue c'est comme si on était voilà
c'est Paris les territoires français
donc le vrai sujet c'est qu'on est
maintenant on peut sortir de l'histoire
et ce soir parce que et donc ça pose la
question de la Chine etc etc donc moi
c'est plutôt ça qui je trouve qu'il
faudrait le dire mettre en exergue
merci Rachid amiral c'est à vous oui
c'est du solide
je suis pas de complètement aux
antipodes de ce que venez de dire enfin
en tout cas ou alors je me suis mal
exprimé mais un mot sur l'Afrique pour
commencer par exemple le sujet est
important
bien sûr que l'Afrique que dans un monde
qui sait globalisé dans lequel qui s'est
fragmenté dans ces modèles et bien il y
a les le sud donc le Grand Sud en
général pas seulement l'Afrique le sud
joue dans le mot jouer pas le bon mot
bien sûr ça donne l'impression que c'est
mais à des choix à des alternatives et
c'est très bien comme ça enfin je veux
dire que bon parfait et dire que que on
nous venons on périphérique oui je l'ai
dit la France est une cohérence moyenne
qui sait qui s'affaiblit et cette
vulnérabilité nous impose de réagir
parce que si on est vulnérable et
coralgies pas on meurt bon bah peut-être
moi j'ai pas de personne moi j'ai pas
envie de mourir et mes petits-enfants
j'espère qu'ils vivront dans un monde
qui est plus proche de enfin en tout cas
je j'ai l'idée du monde dans lequel
j'aimerais bien qu'il vive et qui n'est
pas le monde comme que les que les nos
comptes nos compétiteurs stratégiques
semblent proposer voilà un monde à la
chinoise n'est pas le monde dans lequel
je souhaiterais mes petits enfants
vivent mais c'est personnel et chacun a
le droit de d'avoir son point de vue
différents et notamment un pays africain
pour parler de l'Afrique moi je pense
que la vraie problématique enfin une des
problématiques avec la frite c'est
d'abord que notre modèle pourquoi il est
rejeté d'abord parce qu'on n'est pas à
la hauteur du modèle qu'on a qu'on
propose et que et en même temps notre
modèle il évolue tous les six mois on
invente une nouvelle norme qui qui
déstabilise énormément nos
interlocuteurs qui ne savent plus très
bien où les Européens veulent aller et
c'est vrai que la pire des choses dans
la vie en général et dans la politique
en particulier dans la géopolitique en
tout cas dans la relation internationale
c'est de dire quelque chose et ne pas le
faire il faut se mettre en accord avec
ses actes donc quand on vend le discours
de la Baule plus plus parce que c'est
plus plus en plus donc et qu'on est et
que la réalité nous rattrape et qu'on
est obligé de faire des écarts avec
notre
[Musique]
à essayer de mettre en oeuvre et puis il
y a des points qui sont trop loin et
puis de toute façon même qui sont
questionnables et nous questionnent
là-dessus et moi je pense qu'il faut
accepter ce regard ce regard critique
sur notre propre c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'on entend souvent quand on dit ayant
un discours d'adultes adultes voilà ne
nous imposez pas un modèle bon très bien
donc moi je crois pas qu'on pêche pour
avoir abandonné tous les autocrates
enfin soutenues de les autocrates je
pense qu'on pêche parce qu'on a dit
qu'on ne on serait des démocrates
absolument parfait limpide etc et que on
applique pas on n'est pas nos actes en
conformité que nos paroles et du coup ça
nous est renvoyé
dans les dents et assez logiquement il y
en a du mal on sent très mal à l'aise
avec ça maintenant faut pas être naïf
bien sûr qu'il y a quand même une guerre
qui est une sale guerre une guerre de la
de la calomnie une guerre de la
désinformation
et qui n'est pas du tout drôle parce que
cette guerre elle engendre de la haine
et que cette haine elle va nous revenir
en bourrantg dans la figure et ça c'est
sûr et on a beau dire les Russes sont en
train de piller alors vous allez bien
voir les Africains vous reviendrez nous
dire
c'est absurde cette espèce de joie
malsaine et en plus à court terme ou
même un moyen terme
on est en train d'avoir à côté de nous
un continent nous Français en plus on
est le pays le plus européen qui a le
plus d'interactions démographique même
avec ce continent qui est
progressivement nous déteste de plus en
plus enfin c'est c'est hyper inquiétant
c'est pour ça que le Sud doit être une
priorité et bien sûr je reviens sur la
question c'est pas une affaire de
militaire ça dépasse une affaire de
militaire c'est d'abord une affaire de
politique qu'est-ce qu'on veut qu'est-ce
qu'on ne veut pas qu'est-ce qu'on
accepte comme différence
quelle vision on a mais je pense que la
vision
je répète je me répète mais je pense que
c'est les deux visions extrêmes la
vision de la forteresse ne tiendra pas
voilà et la vision de de tout ouvert en
disant mais après tout
au fond on est pareil c'est pas vrai
justement on n'est pas pareil puisque
les modèles sont alternatifs qu'est-ce
qu'on veut qu'est-ce qu'on veut comment
voulez-vous organiser une plus qu'une
coexistence une coopération une
interaction avec un continent
gigantesque qui est à nos portes et qui
a qui a qui a des choix proprement il
faut qu'on lui propose un choix correct
et bien d'une certaine façon d'outre-mer
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'Afrique ce
commerce et la France en tout cas moi
c'est comme ça que je le vois mais
justement c'est intéressant de faire ce
lien d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens font ce
lien et notamment nos partenaires
occidentaux qui ne comprennent rien
en tout cas peut-être qu'ils ont raison
et que nous on a tort que moi j'ai tort
qui disent en fait vous vous abritez
derrière cette France d'outre-mer mais
ce c'est en fait c'est des restes de
colonies et comme l'Afrique est tôt ou
tard ça partira et parce que vous n'avez
rien à voir avec ces gens-là je suis
désolé c'est pas le sentiment moi
personnellement que j'ai mais ça peut
discuter mais à nous et là avant de
parler de moyens pour défendre notre
part de France outre-mer il faut aussi
qu'on ait une relation saine et
équilibrée que les gens d'outre-mer se
sentent français complètement et que ils
aient l'impression que que on leur
attache la même importance et qu'ils
aient les mêmes les mêmes opportunités
et que etc et qu'on fait et qu'on fait
une différence en fait entre Français
d'outre-mer et un
africain par exemple pour parler puisque
beaucoup de notre de notre population
d'outre-mer et et à côté de l'Afrique et
si on considère vu de France que tout ça
ça peut la même chose alors alors on est
vraiment pas au clair et on risque pas
d'avoir une politique saine voilà et par
contre
si on répond oui à la question
l'outre-mer c'est la France et la France
est aussi outre-mer à ce moment-là
derrière il y a énormément de choses il
y a de la politique il y a du
développement il y a de la il y a de la
il y a du narratif il y a du narratif et
qui doit être en conformité avec nos
actes sinon narratif sans actes n'a
aucun sens et il y a du militaire parce
que c'est vrai qu'on est menacé voilà on
est menacé
on est déjà attaqué sur le plan
économique bon ça les zones économiques
exclusives c'est ils sont pillées et
notamment par la Chine mais pas
seulement et pas seulement les nôtres
tout le monde paye tout le monde dans
cette affaire c'est le Far West donc
première chose remettre de l'ordre et
dans cette dans ce truc dans notre
dans notre maison
deuxièmement il y a
tout le registre de la perception et le
registre de la compréhension et de la de
la cohésion nationale avec l'outre-mer
qui est à recréer et parce qu'on a des
forces extérieures qui cassent ce truc
là et je pense que c'est important et
puis le troisième point ça sera le
militaire bien sûr s'il est si en face
il y avait des velléités de monter un
petit peu les enchères pour vous dire
allez français vous prétendez que c'est
chez vous jusqu'à quel niveau êtes-vous
prêts à payer le prix pour pour défendre
ce que vous considérez être
vous-même une fois encore je le fais
bien de dire c'est pas une possession
c'est vraiment
nous-mêmes et bien il faut être prêt à
montrer et actuellement nos moyens
outre-mer militaires enfin sont
complètement sous dimensionnés je sais
que la marine fait des gros efforts et à
développer des bateaux beaucoup plus
performants pour le faire je sais que
enfin c'est une question que l'armée de
terre à elle est encore très présente et
l'Armée de l'Air également parce qu'on
aura des moyens des moyens et 3 Domaines
la Méditerranée orientale et la Turquie
oui des visions de guerre bien entendu
les tensions sont partout cette zone est
stratégique elle est ultra importante
pour la pour la Turquie elle est ultra
importante pour la Russie donc je
parlais Turquie et Russie
nous avons en face de nous des des
puissances qui ont une vision de
puissance donc ils sont tout à fait à
l'aise dans le Nouveau Monde la
différence de des pays européens qui
sont parce que ce monde n'est pas le
nôtre donc on est très mal à l'aise avec
ce nouveau monde je pense qu'on notre
conversation montre que on est en train
de s'approprier cette nouvelle logique
et la puissance c'est pas nécessairement
mal simplement il faut que les choses se
fassent de façon réguler et en tout cas
c'est pas la régulation à l'ancienne en
disant on est tous la communauté
internationale voilà on est tous dans la
même communauté on est tous pas
finalement peu au bout on est pareil
derrière nos différences c'est un peu la
vision Disneyland vous savez vous avez
un peu de France un peu mais en fait
c'est Disney bon ben voilà et ben non
les différences sont fondamentales les
visions du monde sont fondamentales les
modèles intellectuels culturels
politiques économiques militaires les
stratégies sont fondamentalement
différentes et donc
et donc il faut faire avec la Russie
évidemment quand on voit la carte c'est
ultra important pour elle de tenir la
Méditerranée orientale et de et de tenir
à cause du de l'équation énergétique qui
pourrait les vitales de tenir ou pas en
tout cas avoir une influence très forte
sur les pays producteurs de gaz et de
pétrole que du golf et on voit que ça
marche et on voit que ça marche parce
que eux aussi comme on disait pour
l'Afrique ils ont plusieurs clients et
pour eux c'est assez confortable ce
monde qui se fracture il est confortable
pour plein de gens pour nous c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle mais pour des tas de
gens c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce
qu'on s'a permet de d'essayer de tirer
de mettre en concurrence les les
différents les différentes puissances et
de tirer les marrons du feu et de tirer
de choisir les meilleures options
possibles
alors toute la question pour éviter
alors les potentialités de guerre
existent puisque maintenant le rapport
de force est beaucoup plus désinhibé que
les intérêts sont forts et les
contradictions apparentes
un des bons moyens d'éviter la guerre
d'abord et là je retrouve ce que dit le
schéma mais il a raison la guerre avant
la guerre ça veut dire quoi mon être
capable de dissuader montrer que oui ou
non si on a des intérêts on comprend que
vous en avez que vous en ayez également
ils ne sont pas convergents voire même
en opposition très bien on en prend acte
et on va vous montrer d'abord on va
essayer de trouver un modus operandi et
si c'est pas le cas
et ben sachez que nous on a on a on se
laissera pas complètement faire pour
faire n'importe quoi on a cette capacité
et cette volonté à la fois politique et
de la population
a résisté à la pression pour ne pas
avaler toutes les couleurs parce que si
on commence avec une couleuvre et bien
il y en a d'autres qui viendront
derrière et je reviens et je finis sur
quelque chose qui me semble extrêmement
important et que la guerre en Ukraine a
montré
c'est
l'image que le monde a de l'Europe
je pense qu'avant la guerre du crâne
tout le monde en dans le monde entier
quand moi je discutais avec des gens et
notamment le sud
considérait que les Européens étaient
étaient
complètement des gosses de riches pour
faire pour parler trivialement des
gosses de riches nanties oasifs
qui profitent du système au détriment
des autres d'ailleurs avec un égoïsme et
donc les gens qu'on adorent détester et
qui sont incapables de se défendre donc
en fait une bonne tête de bouc émissaire
quelqu'un que vous détestez tout le
monde converge pour dire ah bah cela on
les déteste tous ensemble et en plus on
peut leur piquer des trucs qui sont
incapables de se défendre ils font peur
à personne
je pense que c'était quand même un peu
une image et c'était l'image que
poutine-navel l'Europe des cadences etc
enfin vous connaissez ça aussi bien que
moi les
Ukrainiens au nom des valeurs de
l'Europe et de l'Occident de la
démocratie ont montré que c'était pas le
cas qu'ils étaient capables de se
défendre
alors que connaissent très bien le
système qu'ils étaient déjà très poreux
avec le système russe donc il savait
pourquoi il se battait en quelque sorte
y compris les russophone de d'Ukraine
donc pour en revenir à votre question
monsieur le Center sur est-ce qu'on a je
vous donne un avis personnel bien sûr
est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de s'aligner sur une guerre qui
est pas la nôtre la guerre justement
Est-Ouest États-Unis et Russie Chine et
qui n'est pas notre guerre je crois que
dans ce domaine précis je l'ai compris
que je pense que les intérêts de la
France
convergent généralement mais pas
toujours avec les intérêts européens
puisque nous avons notre singularité
stratégique l'intérêt des Européens
convergent mais pas toujours avec les
intérêts des Américains donc je suis pas
pour un alignement bête et méchant au
contraire je pense qu'il faut et c'est
ça la stratégie
identifier
qui on est et qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
avec qui et contre qui dans ce cas
précis
je pense que si l'Europe n'avait pas
soutenue l'Ukraine
alors là s'en était fait de l'image de
l'Europe dans tout le pays du Sud parce
que les gens auraient dit ils se sont
dégonflés ils se sont dégonflés alors là
la parole est actes ils sont une fois de
plus incapables de donner de mettre les
actes en conformité avec leurs paroles
il parle beaucoup il donne des leçons à
tout le monde ils sont très arrogants
mais quand il s'agit d'aller prendre un
tout petit peu de risques ils sont
incapables de le faire je trouve que là
dans ce cas précis on a réussi à prendre
un peu de risques à montrer qu'on était
capable
sans essayer de partir en croisade parce
qu'on a été je pense un peu échaudé par
ces ce genre de choses et
que l'image des Européens un petit peu
changé j'ai fait un parallèle avec la
guerre des Malouines la garde malouine
en 82 c'était la guerre froide on
sortait de la de la crise de zoromicile
vous savez les pacifices sont à l'ouest
et les missiles sont à l'Est disait le
président Mitterrand ce qui était
parfaitement vrai
donc il y avait une espèce de grand
pacifisme dans l'Ouest à l'ouest qui
était là à la guerre la guerre la guerre
c'est horrible il faut on est en train
de monter d'escalader exactement
finalement une problématique pas très
loin avec la Russie déjà et
il y a eu la guerre des Malouines
espèce de d'outre-mer lointain il suffit
de relire les textes des les bouquins
écrits par tous les autorités politiques
et militaires de l'époque pour savoir
que la Molen franchement les Anglais
étaient presque en train de les brader
d'ailleurs comme comme ils ont rêvaient
bradé on compte peu de temps avant et
mais ça tient on ne me vole pas je veux
bien le donner mais je veux pas qu'on me
le vol et ils sont battus et ils ont
récupéré les Malouines et moi on a su
après la chute du Mur parce qu'on a
discuté avec nos camarades russes
quand on a discute pendant la phase on
discutait très très ouvertement de tout
ce qui s'est passé devant la guerre
froide ils ont changé leur plan
vis-à-vis de l'Europe en disant
finalement il y a un peu plus de
combativité de fighting spirit en Europe
qu'on avait pensé et les choses
pourraient se passer moins facilement
qu'on ne l'avait pensé parce que
finalement il n'y a pas que des
pacifistes à l'ouest il y a aussi des
gens prêtent à mourir pour leurs idées
et bah d'une certaine façon il y a un
phénomène malouine un peu avec l'Ukraine
c'est à dire que les Ukrainiens montrent
une capacité de l'Ouest à se ressaisir à
être capable de défendre un modèle
et de mourir pour une cause ce que
beaucoup de gens dans le monde ne
croyaient incapables de faire donc je
pense que dans ce cas précis tout en
essayant de maîtriser ce qui à peu près
le cas les choses et pas partir que
n'importe comment je pense que la
posture de la France et de l'Europe
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine n'est pas un
alignement
même si je suis parfaitement lucide sur
les intérêts divergents qui peut y avoir
entre les États-Unis l'Europe la France
et l'Ukraine bien sûr mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas un élément
c'est intelligent et ça a plutôt joué en
notre faveur
sur le regard que porte le monde sur les
Européens mais ça suffira pas c'est sûr
devant nous nous avons des épreuves
autrement plus complexes pas des
épreuves simplement militaires mais
économiques en modèle je pense que
derrière ça il y a quand même une forme
de
renationalisation enfin le monde se
fragmente et donc la question de qui
sommes-nous se pose et je pense que
cette question elle est saine parce que
l'indifférenciation René Girard a écrit
des pages là-dessus en disant de
l'indifférenciation née la violence à
cause de la de la violence mimétique et
finalement quand on différencie les gens
quand on s'accepte sa différence quand
on sait qui on est on accepte plus
facilement la différence de l'autre et
de cohabiter avec l'autre sans essayer
de le de l'attirer dans son comme un
miroir de soi-même et donc je pense que
c'est le monde dans lequel nous sommes
ça veut dire que ça vaut le coup de se
poser la question de qui sommes-nous
nous Français quel est notre singularité
stratégique qui sommes-nous en tant
qu'Européen qui nous différencie
également des autres qui sommes-nous en
tant qu'occidentaux et si on arrive à
répondre à ces questions on aura une
relation apaisée à la fois avec les
Européens avec les États-Unis avec les
partenaires du Sud qui sont par certains
aspects ont des intérêts plus proches
que nous que certains europ par exemple
il y a des domaines où on sera plus
proche des Indiens que des Allemands
parce que la vision indienne sera plus
proche de la vision française que les
Allemands c'est un peu c'est un peu ça
sonne ça peut sonner étrange et pour
quelqu'un qui est d'une génération qui a
porté l'Europe de la défense pendant
quasiment toute ma vie professionnelle
c'est au fond une petite un petit deuil
d'un d'une espérance que nous avons
portée il faut l'admettre humblement ce
que nous avons porté avait ses limites
et c'est il y avait des limites internes
et il faut c'est pas pour autant que
tout est à remettre on n'est pas revenu
en arrière mais il faut l'adapter au
Nouveau Monde qui est devant nous
très bien merci amiral c'était vraiment
une audition impressionnante c'est
normal vous êtes passionné merci d'avoir
répondu à aux questions pointues de mes
collègues je me permettrai juste une
petite réflexion à titre personnel
puisque j'ai bien écouté ce que vous
avez dit sur l'importance de la mère
d'une façon générale il y a un certain
nombre d'années 8-10 ans nous avions
commis un rapport avec trois collègues
sur la maritimisation ou la maritimité
parce que les deux
sur des enjeux stratégiques dans ce
domaine là ce rapport avait été reconnu
comme étant très pointue très
intéressant mais il y a eu très peu de
de conséquences positives je crois pas
qu'on est beaucoup tiré les leçons c'est
un peu regrettable et avec votre
présentation très très fournie je pense
que si on avait écouté ce qu'on avait
dit à l'époque peut-être que les choses
seraient différentes et on voit que les
problèmes que l'on rencontre maintenant
ils surgissent en ce lien de la
maritimisation du à l'Ukraine ce qui est
dommage donc super nous n'avons pas raté
des Rendez-vous de l'Histoire la mère
c'est important c'est pas uniquement
tout ce qui est militaire c'est
stratégique économique de toute première
importance en tout cas merci une
nouvelle fois amiral revenez quand vous
voulez c'était très très intéressant
merci de votre écoute